>> AGARWAL: My name is Amit Agarwal. I'm a
product manager at Google. And today, I'm
excited to talk about two new products that
we announced yesterday. The first one is BigQuery
and the second one is Prediction API. We hope
both of these products will allow you to get
more from your data with Google. Before we
deep dive into the session, we have this covered
on Google Wave where you can view notes and
ask us any questions. We have a bitly link
here, it's http://bit.ly/dr01ws, once again,
dr01ws. Organization and businesses today
live and breathe data. Data is being used
for the variety of different purposes such
as understanding and predicting, user traffic
and trends, improve supply chain management,
better product marketing, sentiment analysis,
and the list pretty much goes on and on and
on. The other increasing walling of data,
a couple of the need for more real-time or
near real-time processing of data and analyzing
the data interactively is what makes this
really very challenging. At Google, we have
built a business on storing, analyzing, and
understanding big data. This is clearly reflecting
the work that we do, for example, in the relevancy
of ads, in the precision of a web search results,
and of course a global infrastructure. Today,
what we'd like to do is to offer the same
data analytics capability and make them available
to all of you. Thousands of Googlers have
been using it everyday and now you can too.
I'm happy to announce two new products, BigQuery
and Prediction API. BigQuery allows you to
interactively analyze large datasets so it
literally helps you find the needle in the
haystack where the haystack can be 10, 20,
50, hundred billion, or even a trillion drivers.
The next move, we're going to Prediction API.
So while BigQuery allows you to analyze historic
datasets, Prediction API allows you to dig
these datasets and predict future outcomes.
It's based on the underlying technology on
machine learning. To top it all, both of these
products are offered as web services. So what
does that mean? Well, they run on Google infrastructure,
they're running on thousands of machines everyday.
So you really don't have to worry about troubleshooting
machines, making sure that services are up
and running, or scaling it. We take care of
all of these. So what do you guys do? Well,
you use it. So what we hope is both these
products will enable us to get Google's deep
data analytics capability to all of you. And
we hope you guys will use it in any and every
business. So what are some of the benefits
of these two products? We talk a little bit
about Google technology. Thousands of Googlers
use it everyday. This is not something we
just got it right now. They've been using
it over a multiple years. I wouldn't touch
much along scalability. Today, we take it
for granted, running analysis on terabytes
of datasets, trillions of those, and getting
the results in seconds. We'll touch more up
on security and sharing as the presentation
goes on, but we pretty much get very similar
security and sharing as you guys are used
to with all Google products. And lastly, we
offer a very easy integration with other Google
products such as Google App Engine and also
Google Spreadsheets. So now you guys must
be wondering, "How can we use your data with
BigQuery and Prediction API?" Well, it's very,
very simple. It's a three-step process; upload,
process, and act. The first part is getting
a data into Google. We announced yesterday,
Google Storage for developers. We have a bunch
of APIs, some tools called GSUtil, and you
can pretty much use any of the compatible
tools to get your dataset into Google. The
next step in the process is actually processing
a data. So once you import your large datasets,
you want to take that data and import into
tables for BigQuery. Or if you're looking
at Prediction API, you want to train a model
based on the dataset. Once the processing
is over, pretty much you're all ready to go.
So in the case of BigQuery you can start issuing
queries against the tables that you just built.
In the case of Prediction API, you can make
predictions based on the model that you just
trained, so very, very simple. Some of you
guys here must be having questions on security
and privacy. Well, we take both of these very
seriously. First of all, for both of these
products, we offer SSL access so that data
is secured within transit. And also, it's
you who owns your data, your model, and your
tables, so you actually decide who actually
gets to use your data, your tables, your model.
Of course, Google really offers flexible and
easy user and group-based ACLs with which
you can decide to share the tables, the data,
and the model. So once again, just recapping
once again, it's a very, very simple process;
upload, process, and act. Now that you guys
understand a high-level view of what we are
doing here, how you guys use the system, let's
deep dive into the details. I'm going to invite
Siddartha Naidu, he's from the BigQuery team.
He'll be deep diving into BigQuery, Siddarth.
>> NAIDU: Hi, Amit. Thank you. Hi, everyone.
As Amit introduced me, I'm Siddartha Naidu
and I work with the BigQuery team and I'm
really excited to be able to share what we've
built with you today. So let me get started.
I want to spend a little time motivating the
product and then diving into what exactly
it is and how you can go about using it. So
big data is now everywhere, there's lot of
it, all of us want to analyze it, and there's
a lot of value in it. But the basic problem
that it presents is scale. And a lot of the
normal tools that we use become either [INDISTINCT]
or often useless. So there have been frameworks
built to make this more manageable to run
your processing across multiple machines.
We use MapReduce at Google. We love it. It's
powerful. It's sophisticated. But it's also
complex. It's also generally used in a batch-oriented
way. You either run a [INDISTINCT] job, you
run a [INDISTINCT] job, you can, you know,
run it and get a cup of coffee and come back.
I mean if you're lucky, that's about how fast
it runs. The things you can do to make it
simpler, you can add layers to simplify how
you access it, how you drive it. But what
we want to talk about today is a product that
is exceedingly simple and really fast. Where
do we find this useful? Well, within Google,
we found a lot of use-cases. And frankly,
this slide doesn't do justice. I just listed
a couple out there and, you know, we are able
to build all sorts of useful tools, all sorts
of useful applications on top of this technology.
And I want to pick one particular example
that we can use to understand it. Take, for
example, if you're running a large fleet of
computers. And all of these computers are
connected to each other. Now, one of the things
you want to do is make sure that they're all
healthy and working as expected. They can
all see each other. So you monitor the network.
You're monitoring various properties of the
connections between them. You're pinging different
host periodically. And you're recording all
of this. So you have this large amount of
data that you've recorded and now you want
to analyze. And here is where a tool like
this would be useful, right? So you're having
a problem and you want to diagnose the problem.
You don't want to be running jobs, waiting
for like half an hour, an hour for things
to run. You want to explore, quickly find
out what's going on. Now, as luck would have
it, there is a group called M-Lab, it's an
open collaborative project that's doing sort
of this kind of data collection for their
Internet. Their goal is to understand the
performance of the public Internet, understand
the performance of broadband usage. And what
they have done is they have collected data
from a number of nodes distributed around
the Internet, pinging hosts, and measuring
how good the performance is, how good the
connectivity is whether there are issues and
so on. And what we've done is import their
data into BigQuery so that they can analyze
the data. And I'm going to take you for a
little demo to their data. So here I switch
to the demo. And let me just describe what
you're seeing. It's a little web application
that I wrote via an API, so in a little--basic
UI on top of it. I'm not proud of the UI,
but that's okay. Well, what we are focused
on is being able to run some queries against
the data. So let's talk with the first thing.
Let's see how big this data. How much did
they actually collect? And what--I have down
here is my cheat sheet because I don't want
to type too much under pressure. There's not
a whole lot to type, but let's go ahead and
count up the size of our data. So that's a
big number. That's 60 billion rows of data.
And we just counted it up. Sixty billion is
a big number. A US Census--I mean the US Census
has collected data this year. Well, if you
have hundred times that data, it still wouldn't
quite be, you know 60 billion records. So
that's a big number. And hopefully, we can
do more than count it. Because if, you know,
all you can do is count it, that's not going
to really do--you know, buy us all that much.
So here is another query I'm going run. And
let me tell you what I'm trying to do. So
what they measure is a ping and they measure
the TCP timeouts that occur against each ping
so that they can see if the hosts are having
connectivity problems. Timeout is one of the
things that get measured. But, before I could
explain like the full query to you, we already
got that answered. This is computed over those
same 60 billion rows. We went over them, aggregated
them up, found their codes where there were
timeouts, counted up all those timeouts, group
them by host and found the top 10 offending
or top 20 host that had problems, right? And
I also normalized it and so on so that it's
really, you know, it's the correct number
not just the most frequent host pinged or
anything, so all of that on 60 billion rows
while I was talking to you. So let me--I want
to show you more but I just want to recap
what we've seen so far, give you a couple
of the details and then we can spend a little
more time exploring data. So BigQuery is a
scalable system. It scales to billions of
rows, many billions of rows, and it's fast.
It's designed to be interactively fast. You
can explore your data, you can formulate queries,
you can fix your queries and run them again.
It's fast enough to do all of that. And you
probably recognize what I was typing there,
it was SQL. The language of interaction is
SQL. It's familiar. And all of this is wrapped
up and exposed via a Web API. I'm making it
available as a Web API, makes it easy to use
over a number of different places, over a
number of different applications in the way
that's most convenient. Amit covered sort
of the brief framework. I want to cover a
couple details about the BigQuery portion
of like using the system end-to-end. You upload
your data to Google Storage for developers.
That part is the same. Now, you import your
data into BigTable--sorry--into BigQuery table.
And what that does is allow us to put it in
a format that is efficient to run our queries
on so that we can, you know, handle all your
queries. One important aspect of simplicity
I want to call out here is you don't need
to worry about indexes. You don't need to
worry about sharding your data. You don't
need to worry about partitioning your data
in ways that are efficient for access. Just
point us at the full dataset and say, you
know, import it and we'll take care of those
details. Secondly, you query it. And again,
there's an aspect of querying out here that
is simple. You don't have to worry about provisioning
machines like, commonly, there's an issue
of like, you know, do I need 100, 200, 500
machines to run my thing? Do I need the machines
to be close to my data? All of that is hidden
from you. You construct your queries, send
them to BigQuery. We will run them across
your data and give you an answer as quickly
as we can. The queries themselves, well, we've
chosen SQL because it's familiar and we use
the subset of SQL that's useful for analyzing
data, stuff that you can slice, filter, aggregate
by all the common operations that, you know,
normally occur. And we have a bunch of functions,
the usual that you expect, mathematical functions,
time functions, that idea of things to massage
data into formats like human readable, or
to extract, you know, parts of your deals
that you need to group by or order by. One
additional thing we've added which is a little
different is statistical versions of certain
functions. So when you're dealing with very
large datasets, sometimes it's useful to trade
a little bit of accuracy for a lot of speed.
And so, what we have introduced as a couple
of statistical operators that allows you to
do common operations like top most, frequent,
or count distinct, and so on. So these are
a sort of optimization features that are available.
What about API? Well, the API is a standard
restful API. We have an endpoint that allows
you to find out what the scheme of your table
is with--once when you've imported your data.
So it'll come back with a list of fields and
their types, and then, endpoint for queries.
You pass it to your query, referring to your
tables in the SQL statement, and then you--it'll
come back with an answer. You can see there
the first--there's a little header section
that describes the result set and then, an
entry for each row. There's also a corresponding
JSON-RPC interface of mapping from field to--I
mean, sorry, address endpoint to JSON method
and mapping for parameters. You can use that
if it's more convenient. And a few words about
security and privacy. The API is protected
with the standard Google authentication mechanisms.
We accept all the common Google credentials.
We use HTTPS to protect your credentials on
the way in and your data on the way back out.
And finally, we expose the tables as objects
in Google Storage for developers' namespace,
you know, in the namespace of Google Storage.
And you can manage your ACLs through the same
tools that you use for Google Storage. You--by
default, we create the tables with private
access so that only you can access and query
those tables. But you can add other owners
or other people who can access and manage
your data, or query your data as you see fit
for your application. So now, enough with
the description, let's get back to playing
with some more data or working with some more
data. Now, a very common--many applications
these days are generating a lot of data to
user-generated content. And Wikipedia is a
fantastic example of that. What they've been
doing is recording the history of their articles
since sort of their inception in a database.
And they've collected the whole history of
edits to each article of each page on the
Wikipedia site. We've downloaded that data
from their public site and imported it into
a BigQuery table so that we can analyze the
Wikipedia data. Now before I get to that,
I've mentioned that there's an API that can
embed in different places. So, I actually
like this shell access to our BigQuery tool
a lot. I've used the Brian M.--Brian Clapper
SQL command tool. It's a nice cross-platform
Python command line for accessing databases.
And what we've done is written a Python DB-API
driver around BigQuery so that we can just
plug it straight into his tool and it can
talk to BigQuery tables. So let's go over
and fire up our demo. So that's the tool.
And this is the table that we're going to
work with today. It was the data imported
earlier this year, a little bit--a little
while ago. So, I want to just list the fields.
Hopefully this will come true. Well, we seem
to be connect [INDISTINCT]. Oh, there you
go, okay, probably just a hiccup in connectivity.
Anyway, so the table has a couple of fields
describing properties of the division, the
title, the database device which namespace
of Wikipedia, it lived in and so on. And the
first--once we had this data in, the first
query that occurred to me was to look for
the most frequently edited articles in Wikipedia.
Now, I can define a little shortcut for the
tables, so I don't have to type quite as much.
And let's do that. So let's look at the top
five most edited articles in Wikipedia. Now,
if--yeah, great. So, it looks like everything
is working fine. Now, Wikipedia has a lot
of administrator pages. So this is not quite
what I wanted because I didn't want to find
out how frequently administrators are, sort
of, you know, making edits. I want to find
out how frequently users are editing articles
about interesting topics, or about topics.
And, Wikipedia divides their articles into
namespaces and so it turns what I want is
actually articles in namespace zero. So all
I've done is go back, edit the same query
that I had out there, put in a new filter
and now I'm looking at just articles that
are namespace zero. So there we go. We see,
you know, George Bush holds the record at
least, as of like January of this year for
the most edited article. And we have some
very passionate wrestling fans out there.
So that's one way to look at the data. Well,
the question is how many people are contributing
to Wikipedia? How many people are making these
edits? So I've a query that does that, and
let me just describe what I'm doing out here.
What I'm doing is I'm doing a sub-select where
I'm looking at the number of distinct contributors
contributing at any given month, and aggregating
that up since overall the data. One--sorry,
one thing I forgot to do which is to tell
you how big this dataset is. I should have
done that, sorry, but I can easily fix that.
So, 313 million rows, so it's done as big
as a 60 billion raw dataset but it's still
a very big piece of data and I've just looked
at the top titles. And now, I'm going to look
at the top contributors, I mean, the number
of distinct contributors in each month since
Wikipedia has sort of been running. And we
can see how that's varied over time. And there
you go. So you can see this clear increasing
the number of distinct contributors going
year-over-year this growth as Wikipedia sort
off and, you know, has been a huge success.
And not just that, I can--knowing that George
Bush is sort of like the most popular article
edited, I can limit it to just articles about
Bush. You can see I have a little statement
there that says, "That the title should contain
Bush," and just looking at those articles,
I can run through and see what that is. And
you see the increase of--between 2006 to 2007
when he was, you know, the President. So,
one thing I want to call out here, you noticed
that I started out by counting up rows. I
selected top by title. I then looked at contributor
ID, so it doesn't matter which way we slice
and dice the data. All these queries run in
about the same amount of time which is only
10 seconds, like, you know, in a matter of,
like, seconds. And I can add in filters, try
out different variations, limit my query to
fewer rows all interactively while looking
at this data. Finally, I want to do one last
demo to sort of show you where we're going.
This is actually some--it's relatively new
things that our colleagues at--who're working
on Google Apps scripts on making possible,
which is to allow BigQuery to be embedded
into Google Docs, particularly Google Spreadsheets,
so that we can access 300 million row tables
within our spreadsheet. So what I have here--and
hopefully this will work, this is pretty experimental,
is a little tool that I can put in a word
like Euler. I--that's, is a mathematician
that I've--and I can run a query. And what
it's doing underneath is running a BigQuery
query fetching the data from our table and
filling it into the spreadsheet. And then
I have a little graph built off of that data
so that stuff can go in there. So you can
imagine like if you don't want to design a
full blown Web App nor do you want to like
expose people to like a shell, you know, developers
like, you know, not everyone likes it. You
can cobble up one of these spreadsheets and
I'll--let me give you a quick peek of what
the script look like. It's not very complicated
but you have a little script--sorry--that
can talk to BigQuery, construct your query
around it, and now you can share this spreadsheet
with anybody else who wants to try their own
word. If anything has a suggestion, I'm happy
to take it and give it a crack in here, anyone?
Cheese, that's a good one. I didn't think
of that. And so, there you have it, well,
the most popular articles on Wikipedia on
cheese. Okay, so I've shown you a couple of
different use-cases. I've shown you the kinds
of data that it can work with, large datasets,
billions of rows, hundreds of millions of
rows, and how you can get them easily where
you want them to have them. So just a recap
on what BigQuery is. It's a tool to do interactive
analysis or interactive speed analysis of
very large datasets. It is easy to use because
it's in a simple familiar language, it uses
SQL for its queries and it has APIs wrapping
it so that it's accessible from everywhere
and embeddable into a variety of context which,
you know, whichever one best suit your application.
So with that, let me hand it back to Amit
and he can continue the presentation.
>> AGARWAL: So how many of you guys like the
spreadsheet demo? Just a raise of hands. And
it makes my job really easy as a product manager.
I don't want to go and type in SQL commands.
I can just take the spreadsheet, share it
with customers, share it with other people,
and just say, "Guys, this is what the results
look like." So what's Siddartha showed you
was how to do interactive analysis over really
large datasets. And oftentimes when we're
analyzing large datasets, we see trends and
patterns which opens up a whole new world,
a whole new way of doing analysis based on
the underlying technology called machine learning.
And this is what Prediction API is about.
I'd like to call our next speaker; we invited
the next speaker Gideon. He's from the Google
research team to talk about the Prediction
API.
>> MANN: Thanks. Is this the right one? There
we go. Ahh, there we go. Thanks, Amit. So
if BigQuery was about analyzing the past data,
Prediction APIs is about using your data and
make predictions on new situations using your
old data. So it's not a crystal ball--that's
not what it is. But it is a tool that we found
very useful inside the company. We're excited
to be able to open up to you guys. We hope
you find it useful. Let me give you some background.
Max and I are in the research group and kind
of our day job is using machine learning to
work on problems supply it and solve problems
that are digging the company. And one thing
that we noticed as we worked on this is that
there is a particular class of machine learning
tools. In particular, supervise classifications
which are broadly, applicable and very easy
to use. So once we had this realization, we
kind of we were off running, and so I'm very
excited to be able to talk to you guys today
about Prediction API which is a supervised
classification Web service that runs over
our Cloud and allows you to embed machine
learning into your Web Apps. So let me give
you some of the details, Prediction API is
a RESTful HTTP service. There are three steps;
you upload your data, you train, and then
you predict. So, it's--you know, it's--none
of the machine learning that we're offering
is really groundbreaking. But I think what's
really interesting is that it's a Web service
and it runs on a Cloud. And what that means
is really three things; one, is that it's
very easy to integrate into your applications,
it's a Web service, it's an HTTP and you can
call it from anywhere; two, it runs on our
cloud and so it scales with your data and
your needs; and three, a lot of the research
that happens within the company, we can expose
to you directly and kind of give you a lot
of leverage quickly. And I think all of those
together would make it really compelling and
interesting. So let me tell you a little bit
of how it works. The data that you give it
is
a set of instance. Each instance is a pair,
a pair of input which is composed of input
features and an output, an output label. The
Prediction API takes that input after you've
uploaded to the Google Storage and built a
model. And what the model does is it maps
input or input features to an output. And
so now with that model, you can issue new
request with a set of input or input features
and then the model will predict the likely
output. So, okay, what is it? It's not magic.
Let me tell you a story. When I was 12 or
13, I went to a computer user's conference
in my hometown and I learned a bunch of things.
Probably, the most important was that beards
are really cool. But after that, I also learned
someone there said garbage in, garbage out
and that really stuck with me and it's really
true and it applies here. You know, the prediction
is only going to be as good as the predictive
features that you give as input. Without that,
the whole thing is sunk. So this example,
it's a language identification task. You're
trying to figure out what language this particular
sentence is in, so we have English and Spanish.
So what the Prediction API does, where really
any supervised classification model does,
is it looks for relevant features in the input
and then it--during training, and it tries
to figure out how those features relate to
our particular output. And then at prediction
time, it looks for those features and tries
to figure out what the likely output is for
those given features. So in case of language
identification function words, determiners
like "the" or "la" are pretty good predictive
features. And so it will learn that those
features are correlated. So "the" it usually
means English and "la" usually means Spanish.
Now, if you'll notice "la" is also actually
an English word, it's the name of the note.
So, features aren't always 100% predictive.
If they were, there wouldn't be anything interesting.
But usually, they're ambiguous and infrequent.
And so a lot of the work in the last 20 years
on machine learning research has been figuring
out how to use ambiguous features and figure
out how to combine them. A lot of the work
has, you know, has been done, it's really
fascinating. Some of the people who have done
the groundbreaking work are at Google, [INDISTINCT].
But actually, in addition to their work, one
of the big changes nowadays is simply the
amount of data that's available. It's like
the fire hose has been turned up to eleven.
There's just so much data out there and that
kind of leads to another saying that in the
field, which is there's no data like more
data. So we're really hoping that your data
on our cloud with our system can really let
you do things that really have never been
done before. So what? What kind of applications?
I mean, really there are an endless number
of applications we expect that this could
be used for. Here are some examples and in
term of the company, we use this kind of technology
for spam classification; good email, bad email
also sentiment analysis. So if you look and
you look for restaurant reviews, they have
like stars next to it, that's all done automatically
using supervised classification, so you have
one star, two stars, three stars. But, you
know, the goal of the API isn't just to give
you these classifiers. It's not to, you know--give
you a language identification classifier or
a sentiment analysis classifier. And the goal
is to give you the tools to build your own.
It's like the old saying goes, you know, "Give
a man a fish. He'll eat for a day. Teach a
man to fish. He'll soon develop a hankering
for chicken cutlet." But seriously, I mean,
these tools are really exciting and we expect
to be surprised by the things that you guys
use it for. So here, there are three simple
steps. You upload the data to Google Storage,
and when you upload, you specify which is
the output label and what are the input features,
and then you make a request to a particular
HTTP end--HTTP Endpoint. And then after some
amount of time, the model is finished, it's
usually pretty quick. And then you can make
predictions using that endpoint. So thank
you for your time. And now, I'm going to hand
you off to Max, and he's going to run through
a demo on how to use it.
>> LIN: Thank you, Gideon. Hi. I'm Max Lin.
I'm the tech layout Prediction API team. So
I'm going to show you how to use a Prediction
API, and I'm going to walk you through on
real examples. So, now, imagine you are working
for--in a multinational company. Not only
you have multiple regional office, you have
multinational customers. So suppose you have
an email address. A lot of international customers
send emails to you. They can either respond--they
can also send tweets. They can make a blogpost,
so you got a lot of customers response for
all sorts of languages. Now, you have a problem
or you want to solve the problem that given
an email, a tweet, a blogpost, how am I going
to respond that? If it's--I would like to--if
it's an English email, I want to forward to
our American regional office and let them
to take care of that. If it's an email written
in Spanish, I may want our Mexico regional
office to take care of that. So the decision
you want to make here is a predictive. Given
an email, a tweet, a blogpost, you want to
predict the language. You want to know what
language it's written in. So think a little
bit, what would you do? Well, you will be
lucky if you have in-house machinery experts
like Google here, but if what if you don't.
You're just a stop or you are working in an
enterprise focused on total different things,
you want a solution. So if you already collected
some sort of data and we will show you to
how you do that right now from this at the
top. So I will show you how. The first step
is very easy one. Upload a set of training
data to Google Storage. So let me show you
how--what are the data you need to provide.
It's a very simple format. It's called comma-separated
value format, so everything is just separate,
by commas and you just provide input and output.
So what's the input here? It can be emails,
it can be blogpost, it can be tweets, you
collect before in different language. And
what's an output? Output is in the first column.
So you see here, we have like 10 instances.
Every instance, the first column, you either
see the French or Spanish, and they are the
target, the output you want to predict. And
what's the input? Input is just the text.
So you can--it can be emails, it can be tweets.
And you just put that in the second column
and that's it. That's--as simple as that.
You just prepare a bunch of these, and you
don't worry about how much value here we have
scaled. We have scalable algorithms. I have
to work for that. So let me upload this right
now to Google Storage. We use GSUtil, and
we copy this file locally to Google Storage.
I already create a bucket called "io10" and
so that's our bucket. And I also call this
data "language_id". So that's it. So your
first step, you upload a set of training that
comes in separate value format to Google Storage.
And the second step is you want to run machine
algorithms and how to invoke that call? You
just make a very simple HTTP post call. As
you see, you will see "/predictions/v1/train",
and you just put the name, you just upload
the big store--the Google Storage. So you'll
see? They're the parameter here, data. So
that's the name we just upload to Google Storage
and that's it. That's the only parameter.
You just tell Prediction API, that's the data,
say, you want to walk through. So let me invoke
that and so that's the name we just upload
to Google Storage, it's just io10/language_id.
And you won't get a response until the--the
training is going out. And our training is
asynchronous, so if you upload like a millions
of records to our--Google Storage, it can
take a couple of minutes. So how do you know
it's done or not? You just make another very
simple HTTP call. Let me show you. So here,
you will still see the prediction. And this
time, you call query. And you say, "I want
those check if training is finished or not."
So, again, it's very simple, you make a HTTP
call and you check the status of the training.
Check training. And, again, the only parameter
is that it did not say it upload to Google
Storage, so this, again, is io10/language_id.
So, it's done. And you will see--we'll also
try to estimate the accuracy. So based on
the data you provide to us, we will try to
estimate how accurate that will be in the
future. So here, we got a number like a 0.95,
so you can kind of use beta. You'll do a pretty
good job based on the data you provide. So
that's second step. So the final step that
once you get a new email, a new tweet, and
you want to know what language that is written
in, so that's--let me show you how to do that.
Again, it's very simple. If you look at it
down here, highlight here, it still is a very
simple HTTP call just like query. And the
only parameter, the data there, is the--again,
the dataset you just upload to a Google Storage.
And so where do you put the new dataset? You
put in a body. So you specify that your data
is set in a JSON format here. I highlight
here. So we have a very simple just JSON format
for you to put your inputs. So here, if you
want to do a prediction on language, well
you can use the particular type called text.
And inside the text, you can put whatever,
new email, tweet, post, the blogpost there.
So let's run that. So if we want to predict--we
get a new English email and we want to use
our training say io10/language_id. I want
to use the patterns we learn from this historical
data from io10/language_id. And, of course,
you want to put the new email or new tweet
you want to classify with. So let's think
of one English sentence say, "What is the
answer to the ultimate question of life, the
universe, and everything?" Here we go. So
we try to make a real time prediction. So
every time you see a new thing, you make a
call, you get a prediction. And we got it
right. And you see up here, so that's English.
So based on your historical data you provide,
we think this is English Prediction API based
on your trainings says that thinks this is
an English sentence. And I don't know if you
look at our example carefully on that, actually,
our trainings that are all in English sentence
come from Alice in Wonderland. So I can bet
in the English--in the Alice in Wonderland,
you never see this sentence in that data.
So what's cool and what's so powerful about
this is right now you have a tool in your
hand and you can use this tool to do all sorts
of prediction. And the key thing is that you
try to predict something you never see before,
so like here. This sentence, you've never
seen in your data, but you can do a right
prediction. Le me just try something Spanish.
Say, we use
the same training say, io10/language_id and
let's try a Spanish sentence, "coda nino es
un artista"--oh, sorry. Yeah, thanks. There
you go. So there you see the input is--you
just send to over where to Prediction API
and you got a prediction, it's a Spanish one.
So, again, I want--the [INDISTINCT] message
here is not a barrier language at all. If
you are looking for a language [INDISTINCT]
Russian, I strongly recommend you to look
at Google language API. There's a much large
number of languages, and much more than just
three language we showed here. The cool thing
is that, right now, you have a tool, and you
can think of--you just think of you're--at
whatever application you are developing, it
doesn't matter if it's a desktop App or it's
a mobile App. And there is a lot of decision
you want to make in your App to help your
users, to help your customers. So if you want
to predict on language which is the [INDISTINCT]
of a language_id is pretty complex, but if
you have training data, you can--like here,
in five minutes, you can right now have a
model you can use to predict on your data.
If you have a lot of transaction history,
you want to look through that and you want
to know, "Oh, this is a new customer, are
they going to buy this product or not?" That's
another predictive decision you want to make.
And, again, if you can prepare data, send
over to Prediction API, you can use our service.
So this--I showed you the first step, uploaded
the dataset; the second step, you just co--make
a very simple HTTP call to training data;
the third step is to predict on a new dataset.
So they are all very easy just, a very simple
HTTP calls. And because our service is very
simple to use, I just show you how to do that
from [INDISTINCT], but I'm sure you can do
that almost from everywhere, it's very simple.
So here, you can see a simple code. You can
do this from Python. And again, it's very
simple. You can do this at, not just Python,
it can be from Python, Java. You can host
this, say, Google App Engine. It's--the possibility
is everywhere. So let me do a recap on all
the key capability right now for Prediction
API. For the dataset, we take input features.
So I showed you the input you can send to
Prediction API. I just showed you a text,
the free phone text and actually you can send
also numerical values. So if you wanted to
create an analysis, you can or you may want
to send over how much money this guy have
in his checking--his or her checking account.
How long is the [INDISTINCT] history or something
like that? So they can be numerical. An output
there right now--I just showed you three categories,
and we support up to hundreds of categories,
so that's the output. For the training, we're
actually [INDISTINCT] many, many state of
the art machine learning algorithm behind
the scene. So you don't see that, but we actually
run many machine-only algorithms. And try
to figure out which one is the best for your
data and give you the best one. And we automatically
start that--and we also perform--the training
is done asynchronously, so you don't have
to wait and you can just go back and check
if the training is done or not. And the last
thing is that, we really want to make this
easy as [INDISTINCT]. So it's an HTTP web
service, and you can call very easily for
either it was--like we said it can be from
Web App, it can be from Google Spreadsheet
uses App Script, it can call from desktop
app, mobile app, everywhere. So with that,
I will give this back to Amit. Thank you.
>> AGARWAL: Thank you, Max and Gideon. So
what do you guys think? So both BigQuery and
Prediction API is in the preview mode. We
open it up to a limited number of developers
and enterprises. And you can pretty much go
to these URLs and sign up for the services,
code.google.com/apis/bigquery and code.google.com/apis/prediction.
So we do want you guys to sign up. We've been
seeing a lot of positive feedback and we hope
you guys will enjoy these tools. Now, I would
like to invite the speakers up on the stage
so that we can take any questions and answer
any question that you guys think. So Siddhartha,
Max, and Gideon, can you guys come up? One
quick question in the URL, we had a title,
so the Prediction API, it's code.google.com/apis/predict.
So it's not prediction, /predict. So we can
probably start. Yes, sir.
>> This question is on BigQuery. So we already
have, you know, on App Engine, the BigTable
and GQL, which takes care of two characteristics
working on large dataset and also taking care
of filter condition, I mean, the dimension.
Why is that we built another one for aggregate
queries? Can't we merge both of them because
aggregate queries are something that we need
badly in Google App Engine on GQL last week?
>> NAIDU: So let me try and answer that question
as best as I can. Both do deal with large
datasets. BigQuery is probably targeted at
even bigger datasets than they're traditionally
used to using in data store. One is more geared
towards building Web Apps where you have user
data sessions you need to query along certain
dimensions, right? The other is more geared
along data analysis. And we're going to work
hard to make them both as internal [INDISTINCT]
as possible keeping, you know, possibly bringing
your data between the two in ways that makes
aggregate queries possible easily and data
store. We're not there yet, but our plan is
to sort of go in the direction of having a
variety of data stores that are appropriate
but accessible to a common interface. So that,
you know, the App I built was built through
App Engine, the demo that I had.
>> Okay.
>> NAIDU: So we're going to make this easy
to get to Map Engine and, you know, use in
a way that's appropriate for you.
>> Meaning you will first have to export all
data into the query data store and then make
the query?
>> NAIDU: So, I don't want to look too forward
into this, but it's more like we're going
to allow you to--let me give you one, like,
possible use-case, right. So, let's leave
data store out, but if you say App Engine
logs. Like there is, you know, there's a question
of do you import the App Engine logs into
BigQuery or not?
>> Logs, you mean?
>> NAIDU: Yeah, logs.
>> AGARWAL: One quick question. We do have
a Sandbox area.
>> NAIDU: Okay.
>> AGARWAL: And we're happy to address any
question in detail.
>> Okay.
>> AGARWAL: It's located very close to the
Google Storage for developers' booth. And
we do have people from the engineering team
there who can answer your questions in detail.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> AGARWAL: All right. Moving on to you, sir.
>> Similar question, actually.
>> NAIDU: Okay.
>> I have an App Engine app that already has
over a years worth of survey data and collected
in it from customers. If I want to add a real-time
analytics to my dashboard, do I have to move
all that data to BigQuery or can I access
the BigQuery functionality from my App Engine
data store?
>> AGARWAL: To make it easy, we'll make it
very easy for you to do it, so as a user you
would not have to import it. We'll take care
of all of that for you.
>> Okay.
>> NAIDU: You probably just--yeah, so we're
going to make it easy to do the same things.
>> Okay, but it's no there yet.
>> NAIDU: It's not there yet.
>> Okay. Cool. Thanks.
>> AGARWA: Yes.
>> I have a question about the Prediction
API. I didn't see it in a demo so I'm just
curious if it's there. Do you offer confidence
levels on the Prediction?
>> MANN: Confidence level on the Predictions
I think that was the question, so, we don't
have that yet. I mean, I think the, you know,
as I was telling you somewhat earlier. I think
the Prediction API is the beginning of a conversation
that we're going to have with kind of all
of you guys in terms of what features are
the most important and where we should push.
That's something that we have internally,
I could absolutely imagine exposing that.
>> AGRAWAL: So, Gideon, we can probably take
one more online question here. What kind of
data-mining algorithms will be included in
the Prediction API?
>> MANN: So it is the question I think everybody
wants to know and we've been a little cagey
about it. Part of the reason is that, we'd
try things out. We have a lot of things that
we do internally, some are public--most are
public, some aren't. And so we're kind of
going through and trying to figure out what
is giving the most value to you guys and what
we can allow it. But, you know, I--unfortunately,
I don't have a good answer now. I expect in
the coming months, we're going to have a much
better answer.
>> AGRAWAL: Yes, sir?
>> Can you talk a little bit about the commercial
model and price poll availability, that kind
of thing?
>> AGRAWAL: So right now, we're in a preview
model, so we don't really have any pricing
and billing numbers. We hope we'll have--a
lot of you guys trying it out. So then in
sometime, we can come up with pricing and
billing models, and provide you the numbers
that you're actually looking for. Yes, sir?
>> Hi. For BigQuery, can you append or update
data in BigQuery tables? And can you run queries
on tables while the import is still running?
>> NAIDU: The short answer is append, yes.
Run queries while appending, yes. Both need
more detailed explanations of like how exactly
import works and so on, but briefly, yes.
Update, no. I mean, this is more for data
analysis, so we're not looking it like sort
of updates to the table but, append, yes.
>> AGRAWAL: And this is exactly why we are
opening it up for preview period. We really
want to understand your features and request
and accordingly prioritize, so that we can
solve you needs and problems. Yes, sir?
>> So you guys have the language API available
using all of your datasets you've used for
language so far. You showed a bunch of other
examples like consumer's sentiment and everything
else like that. Do we have access to those
through any API calls from all the research
you've done on figuring out, like what I mentioned,
customer sentiment or species recognition
or anything else like that?
>> AGRAWAL: Max, Gideon, do you guys want
to do that?
>> LIN: So Prediction API is more like a work
from your data. So, for example, like a language
I just showed before--actually, I don't, actually,
encourage you to use our data. I mean, if
you really want to use language identification,
you should go to Google Language API, that's
the one. We want to show this example and
you should prove--I like to use--see how--what
kind of data you upload to us and actually
what kind of prediction to use.
>> Yeah, I know that's available through the
language API. I'm talking about, are those
other examples you mentioned available throughout
the other APIs like consumer sentiment?
>> AGRAWAL: Well, some of them, we have released,
if you look at Translation API, that is one
of the ways we're just saying, "Use Google."
Whatever Google has learned including translation.
The language which Max talked about is another
one. This one is more of a genetic framework
where it can use your data to train the model
and then do predictive analysis.
>> MANN: Actually, can I jump in and just
say one thing to speak to that. I think we're
very interested in providing a really high
quality APIs, and I think, on for particular
datasets. I think there's going to be a lot
of action both from us and hopefully from
all of you guys in figuring out what are really
useful APIs and how to make them available.
So we're thinking about it. Not, yet.
>> SAGRAWAL: So I'll take one online question.
Is BigQuery generally fast enough for generating
interactive data for user on demand? That
is, are we talking about sub-second response
time or tens of seconds?
>> NAIDU: Well, I think that demo sort of
given a feel for that. We're looking at like
order of seconds responses for datasets up
to hundreds of millions of those, right? The
60 billion row dataset, it can take a little
bit longer, but they're looking at order of
seconds, tens of seconds. Now, how exactly
to use that, depends on your application.
In some cases, it's--within Google, we frequently
use it as a live backing to our user facing
application where a user comes in and generates
a custom dashboard around the query to find
some issue or some track down, some--especially
problem, might as well vary depending on your
application.
>> SAGRAWAL: So, again, I think what you want
to do is very much you want to be very, very
interactive. And the whole benefit of this
is the interactivity and the really fast response
times. Yes, on the right?
>> Yes. So I have a question for the Prediction
API for the training process, do you guys
provide like training feedback so like a confusion
matrix or, you know, like, if you guys do
cross validation, which one's working? Which
one didn't work?
>> AGRAWAL: Max? Gideon?
>> LIN: As you can see here, we try to estimate
that the accuracy and there are various sort
of ways to do that. And we are actually kind
of experiment on that. We--that we have like
a bunch of different methods that are in-house.
And, we like to--here in this period-over-period,
we'd like to see what kind of data you actually
upload to us, what kind of--it ask people
what's you're doing, and we're going to see
what kind of feedback we can actually provide--better
feedback for you. So like--accuracy is one
thing and we have been taking a lot of feedback
we can provide to you. And we love to hear
from you and what kind of feedback you like
and send it to us.
>> Okay. So what's the best way to use? Any
suggestions?
>> AGRAWAL: So we do have the mailing list
and the groups lists on our code site. So
if you go to code.google.com/apis/predict
or code.google.com/apis/bigquery, we have
links for discussion forums where you can
give us feedback and also share concerns and
issues with other fellow members.
>> LIN: Yeah, please send to us.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> AGRAWAL: Thanks. Yes, sir?
>> Yeah, with BigQuery, are the results going
to be compatible with like Visualization API,
the Charts API, or...?
>> NAIDU: So--with the Charts API and so on?
>> Yeah.
>> NAIDU: Yeah. Actually, what we've been
looking--we've made the response basically
match the Chart API as closely as possible.
And what we're actually going to do is look
at providing libraries, you know, expanding
with Chart API Library so I can directly do
stuff like passing like a query and a connection
we'll be creating and it all hides the details
of that from you.
>> Is that--is the query language itself close
to what they specify as data source or, you
know, for making data search query or is it
exactly the same or just a little bit off?
>> NAIDU: It's quite different from the data
store thing. It's actually closer to regular
SQL. It's more, I mean--yeah, it's closer
to regular SQL let me put it that way.
>> So things like pivoting, are you going
to have that?
>> NAIDU: I haven't--we haven't looked that
far, so I don't know yet to answer the question.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> AGRAWAL: So since we're running out of
time, we'll probably take a last question.
And once again, we do have a booth in the
Sandbox area. It's very close to Google Storage
for Developers. Please join us there, and
that we will have members from the Prediction
API and the BigQuery team who'll be there
to answer your questions. Yes, sir?
>> Are the results from the Prediction API
continuous or they, which is stored and all?
So if I want to know relative score between,
you know, zero and one with the full range
of decimals, could I get that or is it only
binary, like English, Spanish, French?
>> LIN: And for now, we support apps. It's
not binary, it's discreet, so we can--right
now, it can support hundreds of categories.
And we have been thinking a lot on the continuous
aspect and that's definitely something we
consider, but it's not there yet.
>> Thank you.
>> AGRAWAL: Thank you all for coming here.
I hope you enjoyed the session. We look forward
to you in the Sandbox area. Thanks a lot.